[Music]
hi everyone welcome to more than Android
notifications my name is Seenu I'm a
developer advocate in the partner
darrell team and I'm Paul Mathews I'm a
partner developer advocate in London so
three years ago on this stage Chris rent
an Android engineer on the system UI
gave this quote and it's a brilliant one
don't annoy the user respect them
empower them delight them connect them
to the people they care about and this
is still very much true today so we will
look at channels and how you can use
them in your app what's new in
notifications and finally digital
well-being but first how to respect your
users so respect your users attention
don't annoy the user respect them some
useful tips so do respect the user
settings so if they've communicated to
you in your app that they want a certain
setting for your notifications then you
should respect that
don't try and override it don't try and
ignore it you should check that the
notifications you're sending are not
blocked that they do still want to hear
these notifications and finally if
you're capable in your app you should
backup any settings that they've told
you about notifications and you should
make sure the synced / installs and /
devices you should use well structured
notifications in your app so making use
of the the styles that we provide such
as messaging style inbox style big
picture a style and you should make sure
that your your notifications are
relevant and timely very example is
using high priority fcm messages to
ensure that the user gets the
notification when you intend them to get
your notification and prioritized
posting the notifications first and then
making them look even better so
loading assets and that kind of thing
some don'ts some basic don'ts don't just
send these notifications kind of forget
about them so we really want you to to
use the platform features that are there
to help you for instance
auto cancel making sure that your
notifications disappear when they should
timeouts is a notification really
relevant after four hours and
synchronizing across the devices if you
know that your user uses your app on
multiple devices like tablets and
desktops you should try and synchronize
notifications that they dismiss on one
or read on one across others so don't
send notifications that are not
actionable the point of notifications is
that they're there to be used the by
definition the user wants to know
something which means they generally
need to do something so don't send them
a notification that just tells them hey
we sync some stuff in the background
this is not the best use of
notifications and finally don't annoy
the user so when you send post a
notification to them you should use
alert once and make sure that they're
not getting buzzed like crazy as I
standing up on stage presenting about
notifications and you should make sure
that the group notification behavior is
representative of what you want so if
you're a chat app maybe children group
notification behavior or summary if
you're something else
so respect the user otherwise they might
just turn off your notifications and
then you've got no way of communicating
to them they might choose to uninstall
your app which would be far worse and we
help there are some platform features
that are deliberately enabled the
notification is being turned off for
instance you can see here the and
notifications being posted and the users
may be keep swiping it away and so now
in in P we prompt the user do you really
care about this notification do you
really want to see this content this
acts on channels so if you're not
describing your channels correctly then
this can lead to some confusion and
perhaps some lost notifications from the
users perspective so let's look more
about notification Charles they provide
granular control to your notifications
for the user so you should
empower the user and clearly channels
are the way to empower them so let's
look at how to use them well first of
all they're now required on all apps as
we've they're required on API 26 and
that should be everywhere prevalent now
they help the user categorize that they
help you catalyze your notifications
that help the user to interact with them
but more on that
and finally they allow the user to
customize their settings so the user has
the final say so if you think
something's important and they don't
think it is they can they can tell you
this so let's look at the best practices
again you should allow the users to
manage their notifications through the
channel creation you should allow them
to maybe deep link into settings to
change these things if they expressing
an interest of working with your your
notification channels perhaps they want
to be able to change the importance of
something so setting the right
importance level for a notification
channel seems like an obvious one but
it's so easy to overlook and finally
user settings you should respect the
user settings as you said earlier but
back them up where you can and don't try
and abuse them by deleting and
recreating other don'ts are only using
one channel this is a clear notification
smell if you like if you've only got one
channel in your application there's
probably something else you need to be
looking at if you provide poor
descriptions for users so that they
don't really understand what the purpose
of a channel is then they're not gonna
be able to make the best decisions or if
you use wrong will or blocked channels
then this is probably you know they're
trying to communicate to you that that
they don't like this content and you
should respect that
and finally spamming the user with
notification channels is it's just not
the best way to proceed so choosing your
channels can really help choosing your
channels carefully you really should
think of the user when you create your
channels not your application not your
architecture think of the user and how
they might want to interact with your
app for instance it's a bad idea to try
and
notification channels around your
importance level that you find important
so hey this is a really high priority
thing this isn't what notification
channels before you should certainly you
should group them around you know
categories of notifications for instance
tagging in the photo or liked posts let
the user communicate back to you how
they see that that type of notification
you should also think about creating
notifications when there's more control
needed for instance if I've on a chat
app and I've got a general channel for
all chat notifications coming in but
then I expressed an interest in
controlling like a family chat group you
should allow you should create a channel
at point and allow the user to dive
deeper and have more finely grained
control and finally lazily creating so
this comes back to not creating too many
groups channels or groups and that is
know if Jing you never receives a direct
message and through your app maybe don't
you don't need to create the channel for
that and then the user can can provide
feedback to you to say look this is
useful or this isn't useful and you
should listen to that so in Android P we
added broadcasts for listening in to
blocking to blocking or changing state
of your notification channels you should
understand those and you should react to
them you should maybe back them up so
the next time you create a channel on a
different device it makes sense and
finally you can you know query these API
is at runtime also to find out you know
how the user interacts with your
channels so now look at what's new in
notifications Thank You pal okay let's
now look at what else is new in
notifications on Android I so first we
added some very updates to make the
notifications easier to read and scan
through as you've probably noticed we
are in more padding's in the
notification and went back and we went
back to using the rounded corners at the
top and bottom the other improvement
that we really love is this smooth app
opening animation that you are seeing
here on a slide instead of closing the
notification and opening the app now the
notification transforms
smoothly into the app which speeds up
the transition more than twice and you
might ask what you need to do to have
this all you need to do is to make sure
that you are starting your activity
directly and your activity starts
quickly since for most users the
notification they care about the most
are the ones connecting them with the
people they care so we enhanced our
messaging style a messaging experience
by adding a new person class once you
use API 28 and if you're using messaging
style in notification you can see that
we have now moved to people's avatar to
the left of the notification and you can
set that avatar but using this set icon
method we also added support for images
and stickers in the messaging
notification by using set data you can
add image in your messaging notification
directly the other feature that I love
on Android is direct reply but sometimes
when I'm replying to a notification I
would accidentally tap on the
notification and that will open the app
and my response is lost but on Android I
you can help the user with this by
retrieving the draft from this extra you
can populate the response in your app so
make the user experience better delight
them if you already support smart reply
in your app we highly recommend that you
use this such choices API to also
display them in your notification
instead of replying to the notification
user can now just tap one of them and to
reply okay here's an example we have for
creating messaging style notification
using the new API so first we're going
to create a instance personal instance
here so we're going to use the person
beuter as you can see we are setting the
name the URI the icon for this person
and this is going to represent the
sender in a message and then we're going
to pass that to this message that we're
creating here
as you can see we're passing the
instance of the person not like before
where we're passing the name of that
person and in this message we also want
to include the image so we're using the
set data method to include that image
and then after that we're adding this
message with another message so we're
adding two messages into this messaging
style notification and then we're
setting this down into our notification
okay so here's the quick summary of some
of the do's and don'ts when you're using
messaging style first please use
messaging style for messages and this
also applies for if you're building for
Android auto or Android wear if you're
sending messaging notifications
please use messaging style in the past
we were seeing developers switching
between messaging style and some other
styles like big picture style in order
to create that big image expansion
presentation but now with set data
method you don't need to do that you can
just use messaging style and this will
create a consistent experience for the
user and it's always good to add that
icon for the people in the notification
so we highly recommend that you use
style icon to add that avatar but if you
don't set the icon we will use the
initial for the name for that person to
create create that varial presentation
and finally if your apps the poor smart
reply please add that into your
notification so you're creating a better
experience for the user and here's a few
things that you want to avoid there are
a lot of good reasons to auto cancel a
notification in order to give the user a
cling and up-to-date notification jar
but after user replies to a notification
a messaging notification this is not one
of those cases you would want to keep
that notification there so if user want
to return to this conversation and reply
afterwards so please don't cancel that
and let the user swipe away when they're
finished with the conversation the other
bad behave
that we've seen in the past is some
developers are you setting this empty
name in order to achieve a viral
presentation but our entry night please
don't do that there are two reasons one
is because it will break on Android 9 on
the presentation and the other and the
other reason is because a person without
a name is not a real person so up until
now we've talked about how you can reach
the user how you can help your user
connect with people they care about and
how you can make your notification a
better experience for the user but I
want to hit a stop a hit a pause here
and look at app usage from the other
side since as much as I want to get that
notification from my friend and family
as you need time away from the device
so to help user with this we announce
the digital well-being at i/o this year
if you have a pick up device running
Android I I highly recommend that you
download it from the Play Store and sign
up for beta so this is what digital
well-being will show us it provides a
overview of our app usage and provides a
dashboard that shows our time spending
on each app and the number of
notifications that we received
I've personally loved using digital well
being to learn that where I'm spending
my time but sometimes I would find that
one or two apps are sending me a lot of
notifications unexpectedly so one
question you might have is how are this
notification counted since this is still
in beta the counting method may change
but the goal is to track user
interruption interruptions
so in general and in newly created
notifications are counted as one and in
any updates that's visible to the user
are also counted as one which means if
you are sending a notification to the
blog channel that is not counted here so
in this case I saw this app is sending
me lots of notifications so I got
curious I went into the dashboard and I
when that to see the overlay breakdown
and as you can see here I got a
notifications every hours a day and even
at 4:00 a.m. in the morning I got eight
notifications so if these notifications
are high importance I would be woken up
in the middle of the night but
thankfully that's not the case but if
these notifications are push
notifications and they're sent using
high priority FCM message which means
this app is constantly waking up a deep
dose device if I won't have good battery
in the morning I might just uninstall
this app but for now I will turn on the
nd Do Not Disturb so that I don't get
disturbed digital well-being also
provides ways for users to disconnect
and reduce interruption and now picks of
three you can even turn on D and D by
simply flip your device which is super
convenient but what if this is super
important a notification that the user
actually wants to receive so for those
here's a few advice for you first set
the right category to your notification
as we can see here in the do not disturb
setting user can choose what to block
and what to allow and they can set
exceptions on calls messages reminders
and events if your notification belongs
to one of them please tag your
notification as such here I listed a few
categories which corresponds to these
exceptions on the other side as I said
if your notification belongs to one of
these categories please let us know by
tagging them the other advice that we
have is if this is a notification coming
from another person then please tag your
notification as you can see here in the
digital in the do not disturb setting
user can choose who they want to get a
notify from from their contacts so
please add that person in your
notification and associate and add the
associated URI if possible do
this will allow you to bypass to now
disturb but you should always remember
that when user turned out without
disturb they really don't want to be
disturbed so if you're sending a
notification that's not expected that
will really annoy them so please don't
abuse this api's which this brings us
back to the code we had at the beginning
where we're saying whenever you're
sending a notification please keep this
in mind don't annoy the user respect
them empower them delete them and
connect them to the people they care
about thank you
[Applause]
[Music]